well yes i i think we've been fun to
talk a little bit about magic squares
and uh magic squares have fascinated uh
mathematicians and and artists as well
for many hundreds of years
and i'd like to show you just uh a print
is called melancholia one by uh a german
uh artist and in this you can see a
rather plump melancholy angel with
various uh mathematical devices she's
holding a pair of compasses in a hand
there's this complex geometrical object
here there's a sphere down here and then
various uh tools and objects and also we
can see a wonderful comet and a rainbow
time is passing and up in the top right
uh right hand corner we have
a
magic square and if we zoom in on this
it's written in slightly old-fashioned
symbols but somewhere okay so this is
written out in modern versions of the
numerals the magic square that appears
in dura's painting of melancholia one
and if you if you look at this
you'll see that all of the
rows so this row if you add those
numbers up 16 plus three plus two plus
thirteen hours up to thirteen four
thirty four and if we look down this
column here thirteen uh three plus ten
plus
six plus fifteen that adds up to thirty
four uh and then if we look along the
diagonal if i remember correctly that's
26
and then that's also 34 and this
diagonal is also 34. and we've
got a 4x4 square here notice and we've
used the first 16 numbers
to fill
that square and that's your typical
magic square now this one really
fascinates me
i've got it hanging up
at home and um
i was looking at it one day only a
couple of weeks ago in fact and i
discovered something that i've never
seen before and i've looked around on
on wikipedia and not not seen any
reference to it but if you add all the
numbers in melancholia so if you add all
the numbers of of the magic square and
we've seen that each college of the four
columns has 34 so if we take four times
uh 34 we get 136 and then if we look for
one more number
in melancholia it's called melancholia
one and if i add one 1
to 136
i get 137. and this is approximately
equal to 1 upon alpha my friend the fine
structure constant which tells us the
ratio of uh the strength of the uh
electrical force to the quantum
are you suggesting this some consider
some some meaning or something no no
it's purely coincidence but well i think
it's purely coincidence but it's i think
it's very funny and it's not very widely
known so i i'd be great if we can put it
into 60 symbols and do do do word
squares i mean i've been fascinated with
these things since i've been a kid and i
played around seeing if i could make
them and i started off with a nice
simple odd three by three number square
and i wanted to try and make all the
rows and columns add up and i think th
this the the rather plump angel here
just looks like a physicist and she's
obviously worried about infinities or or
integer numbers or the volume of this
and thinking about spheres or maybe
she's seen this comet on the rainbow
wondering about it it's just delight to
a physicist to see it so i find them
she looks very patient just thinking
away the problems and that's what we
have to do and when we get a bit
melancholic and depressed we have to
press on with our calculations and do
our experiments so i find it just
inspiring